and finally new rule now that it's April
15th all US taxpayers must call out all
the deadbeats who ride for free which
include giant corporations like GM and
United Airlines which this year are
gonna pay no taxes how brave of you but
the list should also include this place
and this one and this one and this one
and this one
there are 300,000 religious
congregations in this country that paid
no tax no federal state or local no
income sales or property tax and they
own 600 billion dollars in property like
st. Patrick's Cathedral on Fifth Avenue
in New York
if you sell cheap sweaters like they do
across the street at forever 21 you pay
taxes but if you're selling the
invisible product of eternal whatever no
taxes
so to recap forever 21 taxes forever 33
no taxes
you know Scientology founder l ron
Hubbard once said that the only way to
make any real money in this world was to
start a religion and even though the one
he started only has about thirty
thousand members it owns billions in
real estate tax scot-free and that makes
me hopping mad the Supreme Court of the
United States really needs to take a
case about taxing churches because it
hasn't done that since 1970 and since
then religion has become much less
popular especially with younger people
so then religion is the new pubic hair
35% of Millennials want nothing to do
with it and the rest worship an ancient
Jew born over 2,000 years ago Bernie
Sanders
and it's not just Millennials my flock
the atheists agnostics and anti
religionists out there are now the
second biggest denomination in America
right behind of angelical x' we're 22.8%
that means almost a quarter of us in
America are being forced to subsidize a
myth that we're not buying into why am i
subsidizing their Sunday morning hobby
they don't subsidize mine
if we levy taxes sin taxes they call
them on things that are bad to get
people to stop doing them why in
heaven's name don't we tax religion a
sexist homophobic magic act that's been
used to justify everything from genital
mutilation a genocide you want to you
want to raise the tax on tobacco so kids
don't get cancer okay but then let's put
one on Sunday school so they don't get
stupid
Americans are losing their religion
because they're catching on that
religions do much more harm than good
who enabled child sex abuse for
centuries what's the common thread
between Isis al-qaeda Boko Haram and
most other terrorist groups in the world
who's behind the new law in Mississippi
that says that Mississippi now cannot
among other things force a baker to bake
for a gay wedding
because in Mississippi if you don't put
it in the right hole you don't get cake
and speaking of cake it's the same
religious freedom people that last year
passed the law in Indiana that allowed
restaurants to refuse to phim gay people
as Jesus would have wanted ah yes
sweet sweet religious freedom free at
last to eat the potato skins here at the
flapjack hunt without some gaylord
forcing his penis and our good Christian
food and turning it gay you gay pee you
gay people hungry well you should have
thought of that before you embarked on
your life of satanic perversions next
time have sex in a vagina and if you
take a picture of it and bring it in to
Bennigan's you get a free appetizer